you
hi everyone is Jerry come on leeches org
and I'm ready to play a 15-2 game let's
try d4 all right let's see what we get
slavi e6 a capture a slob
well let's go boring with this one I
don't know how many times I've played
this variation in standard this may be a
first and we're just going to make sure
this guy is outside the pond chain so
we're going to try to squeeze some
advantage from this
I don't think it's so bad III I'm just
covered d4 and standard moves the nice
coming out but I do want to delay my
King night I don't want to see a quick
pin
so will black try to deploy the Queen
Bishop outside of the pawn chain just as
I have is a big question
the bad bishops are the queen bishops in
this case
okay I'll go with the night first maybe
tying up this idea night b5 in to c7
it's not quite there because of Queen to
a5 a6 is a pretty typical move to watch
over b5 and also preparation for an
expansion on the Queen side this is
usually the side of the board where the
play will come about there's not too
much excitement on the Queen side pretty
symmetrical so there will be a fight for
the C file and sometimes a Knights
jumping into c4 c5 squares so let's see
moves I'm considering up to c1 Bishop to
d3 Knight to f3 which one to go hmm so
I'm going to stay a little bit flexible
with my king side minor pieces
so here's another thing if I played
Bishop here straightaway night to be
four and I guess I could return to e2
but on my next move Bishop d3 night to
b4 is conveniently met then with Bishop
to b1 and my Bishop is not blocking in
my rook he's where he wants to be right
now
you see that in some positions one
that's coming to mind is a variation out
of the caro-kann pan off Botvinnik
attack basically deploying the Queen
rook prior to the king bishop so that
you have that convenient retreat so
let's see with what chess chess eree
comes up with all right
so in the end opting for a fee and keto
hmm I'm not used to seeing that
five and Bishop to g4 or coming to minds
so many times I feel that the bishop on
g7 can just be out of play
unless an e5 strike can get in and d4
can be struck out he's kind of biting at
a rock hmm okay well I know where the
dark square bishop is going so one of
these two or maybe even a ch3 is what's
running through my mind right now
not sure what the differences are uh you
know what I'm just I'm going to make um
I'm going to make one more prep move I'm
delaying the kingside minor pieces once
more but
I'm doing this to make sure there's not
going to be this type of an imbalance
and now that there's no fear of Bishop
g4 the knight definitely belongs here
Knight to e5 in probably Bishop here
need to play 2e2 there's not going to be
some kind of pin now what could happen
is that black still tries to get the
bishop outside to punch in so I don't
think double def cons would be such an
issue
have an idea connected with if they do
decide Bishop f5 takes takes I do have
an idea for g4
this is something that Springs about
once more second time I'm referencing
this opening but the Carroll Khan
exchange variation you'll see this idea
where black tries to get their Bishop
outside the pawn chain playing Bishop to
f5 and one of the benefits of having
double def cons is it increases blacks
control over 84 so
I'll be having to work around a knight
on e4 if that comes about but maybe
there's a way I could get at the king I
haven't committed my King just yet so
that's why an idea like this with the
capture and then g4 is uh you know has
has some points to it I can't go Queen
side but I guess I could stick around in
the Senate a little bit so here here
takes push
chop-chop-chop is probably way too risky
for black
that's night that night is unprotected
and and stuff like ninety to g5 or
Knight to e5 are coming to mind with a
discovered attack I'm not sure if I'll
pull the trigger on that to be honest
the capture and then g4 what would I do
on Bishop to f5 what are my options
I always ignore it just throw my knight
in the center or something castle we'll
see they're probably winning this move
you know d5 not so much because I have
some tactics against c6 so if not Bishop
to f5 then want c6 be happy to see that
I'm thinking they'll play Bishop to f5
so what am I thinking of so what's my
reply going to be
capture or castle
I don't know chop chop
okay so
you know here's another thing they may
be delaying Bishop f5 wanting me to
first castle then I'm less likely to go
forward with the capture in g4
okay
well they're preparing a five this is
also again maybe the waiting move for
the Bishop f5 idea I think I should just
get castled so much for this kind of
stuff anymore very solid for both sides
I'm just to move away from connecting
rooks they're two moves out very minor
points turn not quite adding up to be
anything significant at this point they
can't try for
just yet supporting me five because d5
is would be unprotected okay so they're
really trying to push through with you
five so they're going to get that out
let's back up that was the point of h3
so they're really gunning for this move
so ah to be honest I wouldn't mind
seeing this this is a desirable
structural change transformation if they
end up with an isolated deep on this I
feel pretty good about and that's
basically what's going to happen I can't
allow this so let's start with breaking
up their pawn duo and we'll probably
have two sets of minors off and in the
end I want my knight here
hmm yeah I probably just want to go
forward with capturing twice on e5 it's
kind of double-checking I guess this is
something to consider this actually
might not be a bad move this might be a
best move
something that's keeping me from just
chopping away on the e5 squares that in
the end the rook is on e5
and I would like to really quick at my
knight in 2d for but what concerns me at
least a little bit
is like something so some major piece
arriving on g5 and then some capture on
h3 though and I wouldn't have to fear
I wouldn't have to fear Queen g5 because
I would have f4 with the fork rook here
it's a bit clumsy looking
but I also feel that Bishop to e2 is
just really strong
because wait a second I may be winning
upon with this retreating move
Bishop to e2 I'm hitting it d5 twice how
they defend if they capture first I
recapture and now I'm hitting it would
be a third time and it's only defended
once so it's going down
a bishop now on the e2 square is
striking up this night and h5
okay so these are the two moves I'm
considering I think actually Bishop e2
is good
hmm
threat to win upon and also the threat
to take here and then take here twice
what am I missing
Oh
Bishop b2 suppose they take take and
maybe d4 but I could take take here I'm
ready to take twice on this square and
completely destroy their king-sized
structure I don't know I think it's the
best let's go with it
the ship c2
so now what are they going to do here
they can't just go away with their night
because II five is then a goner hmm oh
you don't think I play anonymous here
they have Knight to c4
maybe 94 I could give him a boot
maybe two he's probably going to get
hunted down so 94b three the night would
have to go here and then I'm winning
this next
any variations connect
at the bishop giving itself up for the
night
to prevent me from maybe winning the d5
pawn in some way is definitely not you
know he's probably worth four points so
/ super valuable Queen still on if the
Queen's are still on and you're giving
up this key King side defender
your opponent still has a dark square
bishop on top of it all that's really
the main thing you're giving up your
dark square bishop your opponent still
the dark square bishop you know this
bishop for night in bounce bishop for
night exchange in your opponent still
has a dark square bishop you're really
asking for trouble
may not be apparent straight away how
white can maybe take advantage of this
but this is just a long-term feature
something you really shy away from
before probably bullet
really
okay now we we have played a 15-2 game
wasn't Terri calling
I'll back
okay pick out what kind of opening that
was
so they are in the think tank here and
what you do I'm having a difficult time
suggesting move for black
I have a court grip on the kingside
this structure here has a name and that
is it
Foursquare's very solid compact
structure
oh no significant gaps on you know Kings
side of the board here lights Kings side
could identify two gaps on blacks King
side two holes
yeah what mark
there are no there are no holes with
this configuration at any moment you
know all I said all these are controlled
but you know these four squares but
there's also these two directly and
these guys can only step up and control
these two anyhow
term I came across from it's used in the
book pawn power in chess not a book that
I've gone through in its entirety but
I've checked out some of it that was one
of the terms
you know so
the delay here is saying something about
the position there's a something has
gone wrong here that's this idea with
trying for e5 is really not working I
don't think I know maybe I'm missing
something had games like that thinking
I'm going to be winning upon or a piece
and then yeah doesn't quite turn out
that way I miss a little detail no I
don't think I'm missing a detail here
though
hmm
under the five minute mark it really
does feel like I'm gonna win upon
I'm not behind a development in any way
so I don't not sure how black will maybe
try to show some compensation for maybe
being down upon soon
maybe takes takes Knight f5 Knight f6
and then you know I can take here make
it take care okay they're going in for
Knight to c4
so with this I had in mind simply b3
Oh b3 they have to go here b3 they're
going to go here that's a little bit
awkward but they're not going to be
losing upon
consider
for example if I capture here and they
recap and they recaptured the Queen I
get to take it's my night and I'm
hitting everything getting c4 and on top
of it threatening a fork and c7
so on this I think the reply will be
Knight takes b4
I'm almost certain that this is winning
for white
the wind of upon but there's some way to
just flat-out win right about now so
this is also appealing straight straight
away going in for Knight to d5 that's
probably the backbreaker
hitting the knight twice and threatening
this so Knight takes d5
he's just an absolute monster in the
center connected well with this guy
Knight takes d5 Knight takes b2
and I just need to find a spot for my
queen
hmm
it takes d5 night
be - the night is defended from in that
position it takes d5 Knight takes B -
Queen to b3 is what I was thinking
Bishop to e6 okay
just give him a shove but I think I want
to pick up the d5 pun right now
b3 here
do I have anything good from that
position I don't think so
let's see and I think I want to go in
for well let let me want to consider
this night takes maybe just Knight takes
e4 mmm our Bishop Bishop takes e4 pawn
takes and then Knight to d5
packing c4 in threatening night to c7
soon
you
this is tough
not sure what to do
[Music]
b3
these two on d5
night xb2 maybe Queen to c2 or Queen to
d2 and clean the d2
that night sure does look a little bit
stranded
my queen on d2 is protected by my knight
this move which has to be pretty
annoying
all right
on marchek here queen takes d5 as a
start
Dean takes d5 Knight takes b2
no I want to play this position
with the Queen still on so opt for
taking and defy with the night
shoot up a lot of time
but
critical moment
yeah
pressure on the night my queen is
defended so he's not pins and now how
are they dealing with Knight to c7 I
also have no I don't have that
you know I want to jump my knight into
c7
they just move there
here
I want to go to c2 because it allows a
deployment with an attack
this night whenever he moves there's the
punch turn at this guy
I can't go here because you know he's
not defended anymore Knight to d4 would
cut off the coordination between Bishop
and Knight but also between my queen and
night
Oh if the hrickos here sidestepping this
little fork then I do have Knight to e5
this is I'm a couple connection squares
here both both of these Knight jump sir
defended or supported by my bishop and
for a moment I was thinking oh maybe
this rook moves no mister I can't go
there so this is this is a difficult
moment for black what to do to sidestep
the fork they wanted to play the bishop
but I don't believe they could do that
and just jumps in there
hmm
you
rip to Fe
Knight to e5
you
yeah and then this night has to run away
and when he does then this rook will be
what what am I missing here they're just
going to give up the exchange maybe they
get a pawn for it well they would have
two connected passes on the Queen side
but okay I think I think right around
here I just I have to jump in to c7 it's
just hitting everything
yeah the rook may end up I think I just
have to jump in here
we'll see
see what happens
are in Bullitt mode now
okay gotta get the clean you back
there's an
see checks I could throw in there
okay well here's another thing when I
take the second on this guy
takes here it could always take
you're first to get out of this
okay I
where I simply grab the materials so
that reps a downer
and yeah this kind of make
turn out to be a nightmare no way
even without the Queen's on the board I
was speaking earlier with the Queen's on
the board rook takes knight Knight takes
bishop
rook takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
and got a check we got another check
and controlling these on the flight
square the only flight square for block
the night on b2 would be defended with
the rook on my second so here we are
maybe I just want to take here first
once the body count if I take this night
they have to take with the pawn first
we capture if I do this the night
recaptures they save their kingside
structure and then I'm having to deal
with this threat against my bishop
just take the night right now
takes nights
thing other than the recapture and then
I take here they gotta take here I could
insert this check they could block I
could take the ninth the RIP recaptures
then I could go here force off the rooks
and just be up a clear exchange if they
avoid the crook exchange that I'm
winning be - I can deal with one pass
pawn - maybe a bit of a different story
take out the name
anything better than bishop check and
giving up the bishop and getting rid of
this guy rook to be one
hmm
let's start with this check
react
can move
moving forward
take the night
here right now the night moves and
throws a punch at my bishop one way or
the other
I think I just want to get rid of them
now this endgame the Bishop's going to
be pretty strong but
let's give it a shot here actually
what about Bishop here is that do
anything
I should hear rook here and then do this
and I think I want to just make it
really simple so you know they're going
to have a tough guy here on e6 start
with this they should keep the rook on
so there we go
and now I want to get behind this pawn I
don't want him to get too far advanced I
definitely don't want them to get here
that's just way too far advanced now
right around this point what I'm
thinking is give up my rook for this
Bishop and this outside pass pawn invest
a little bit material then end up with a
healthy four versus three on the Kings
side I think that's my best bet
um for starter
is what do we do here
I think I just go right behind the pond
and I'm not sure what files
this one the bishop is in controlling
these three and yeah I think this is
fine
you know these rooks can be
the bishop or pawn in some way they
could cause some trouble to the king
functioning on these adjacent ranks
okay
well
don't want to do this I'm dropping f2
can insert a check
let's start with this check don't know
if it's best hesitant to move this
because of this bishop move okay I think
for starters
I think I just want to make sure that
that Bishop doesn't go any further this
is another move I want to kind of way
for and then I have a home here H for
push here check and then the pond gets
here let's just make sure this pond
doesn't even get here successfully
this might be a little bit annoying for
me
okay well I got what I want like I could
sack here this is I think this is what
I'm going to go for
yeah I think I have to do that
he's just way too good of a bishop so
I'm going to try this being up upon in a
perfect structure he belongs here
I could try to win this he belongs here
maybe not to improve the King he can't
go here anyhow
and he's going to go here
once here and now that move huh
I need to do this for my rook enough to
making up a little bit more this prong
controls these two so in a way it's like
a three versus one
let's just get over here
you
you know this is not so easy to win I
could try this and not push playing very
fast that might be a bit of a mistake
let's let's see if they give this check
that's a losing move I'm pretty sure now
this wits check
meek up here there's no fancy stalemates
I'm just down on time
this is a this is a one end game
game yeah I think I needed to do and do
how I did with sacking the rook for the
bishop and outside passer it was just
too good of coordination going on
you know he's protecting this guy look
at the base points the just way too good
and I don't know these record also do
not like to you know be defending
against the silly little pawn push and I
do not want to allow him to get to a 2
so I know I think my conversion was fine
I to be honest I don't know if this is
really winning
I mean the final position was but right
around here if they don't allow this
little push right here with e5
you know so when I did this I was just
testing to see if they gave the check
and I was going to return and then come
up with something else but they can also
just kind of get out this pin right now
I was saying also that this one pond
restricts these too but
I don't know if I'm ever doing this then
that's not the story anymore they get to
undable and and I know the presence of
their each pond
the reason the remaining H Pond is felt
and he holds up my ponds so I'm not
quite sure really how to move forward if
you know I think there's definitely a
way that black could put a better
resistance in this endgame backing up
and
I'm not sure what I do
my king but the rook is always in a
position to maybe question my king I'm
not sure it seems it's not completely
clear to me as you could probably tell
so yeah but before going into the
analysis what more to add I think on I
could have replied in a better way to
this 'if I've move maybe maybe capturing
away and then trying for a reposition
that's the strictly positional way to
approach it just playing against the
isolated pawn that's where the knight
would belong difficult to challenge I'm
only one piece around that that could
and even even if that comes about where
the Knights are exchanged the dark
square Bishop star exchange and I get
the knight to d4 even if he is exchanged
there's the Queen who could take up a
really nice post on d4 so I think
overall this middle game plan with e5 in
this exchange Slav really isn't
something that's so good for black
planwise some kind of pawn break I think
this mentioned blue Bishop f5 is better
a better plan King and then on the e5
square and solving the bad bishop
problem just making sure he's out and
about let's dive into the analysis board
and
request a computer analysis and see what
it has to say cycling through here
running a couple engines or excuse me a
couple lines stock fish ate one engine
two lines you know so I don't know I was
pointing out all these different moves
but I don't know that the order really
matters so much
yeah h3h3 903 and I played h3 just
avoiding any imbalance you know I don't
want to give up this is my bad bishop
but still I don't want to give up the
knife for Bishop
you just have an advantage so this this
point right here now it doesn't suggest
this Bishop f5 move but I can't imagine
that it's yeah I mean something you
could definitely do takes takes plus 1is
oh yeah now okay so this anxiety of g4
is really something
ta
I cancelled and then maybe Bishop here
is a different story because it won't be
suggesting g4 right now so this is maybe
something a little bit different to make
this yeah now it's a bit of a passing
move like faking that you're going to
play for a five and you just want me to
first castle so you can play Bishop
about five and have no fear of the
exchange and then g4
Bishop f5 here
so likes Bishop f5 now so doing it one
move sooner
while I'm not castled
so this is interesting to know I just
want to look at this a hair so it does
not want to take here this is just too
much of play it takes g4 and it likes
Knight to g5 night h7 and hit
you know this is this is probably
approaching a winning advantage suggest
Queen to d7 what's probably pretty
human-like is to get the knight out of
line in the line of fire and defend h7
and now Queen c2 insisting h6 and now
here wow that's some pretty direct stuff
looking to chop off the knight and then
clean h7 ball game so clearly there can
be an attack that Springs about right
away earlier when I said I played h3 it
was to preserve my bishop and that is
clearly the primary function behind h3 a
secondary function
you know we're clearly seeing a line
here where if they try to deploy the
bishop outside the pawn chain
at this moment right here well maybe
there's an additional justification
behind h3 of supporting g4
trying to go after the king
the jeep on
they have a
Aitor grip over efore but no no jeep on
a slightly weakened King position
because of this capture
additional secondary reason behind h3 so
what is the graph thing
okay that's where we stand
these mistakes and blenders for each of
us
hmm let's see
'if I've you know so I just don't think
that this is the right idea to go in for
e5 there's that Bishop f5 movies is
better it does like Bishop to e2 here
it's not Knight to e5 first but it does
like Bishop e2 as a top move now Knight
to c4
it likes to reply Knight takes d5 Knight
takes B to Queen to d2 just wanted to
stay off of light squares pretty much go
to b3 or c2 I'm getting hit by the
bishop so clean d2 and yeah so I guess
this is just a winning advantage now it
felt like it was well I don't know
that I felt that it was winning at this
point with Bishop to e2 but after Knight
to c4 I think I was voicing that it felt
like there's some killer continuation
where are we at on the graph so plus two
point six and well that drops it drops
down quite a bit at some point only
about a pawn advantage and then you know
so it does drop off some on move 30 so I
guess I played it alright for a little
bit here
coming in for this fork and it really
isn't a great suggestion suggestion
coming up or computers not coming up
with a good suggestion here for black no
great continuations
played Bishop e6 a c7 what are the
alternatives this
I thought Knight to e5 oh okay that's an
okay move as well but Bishop to c7 Queen
d7 whoo look at this little finesse
what's that about and just picking up
the night
the d4
have to look any further here I mean
way to back into a completely open
position I have this there's a fiend
cutout night there's a night on the edge
so and have a good Center rook on the
open file so there's going to be
multiple ways to win from there multiple
good lines to choose from Queens are
gone and now yeah I'm just picking up
the exchange so I should come up with
something different okay it likes
capturing okay so here it doesn't like
rip to be one is that where there's a
drop-off no not quite it's still fine
with this but I guess it wants to yeah
each for yeah
I don't really have too much time to
consider that I just wanted to make sure
that this guy wasn't getting to e3 too
fast but I guess I there's a good way to
move forward without cashing out and
sacrificing the hook for the bishop and
passer so give it check now h4
yeah
this is the other move I was considering
but I didn't really have time to do it
and the reason I don't think I expressed
why I would want to play h4
it's because I want to eventually have
my last piece contributing the send game
and if Black gets this in I don't like
how do I activate my king
district stays here if I ever do this
they're taking and my king is still cut
off so how do I get my King to the third
rank is really the short summer here if
they're able to establish a pawn on H
form I will not be able to successfully
get my King to the third rank and as a
result the fourth rank etc I can't get
my king activated because of this one
pawn that's now posted in my house so
that's why given more time I would
strongly way this h4 move because now I
have a path forward I'm just kind of
making a passing move well okay it's not
good passing move let's just say I don't
know whatever rook here I could play a
move like this or first extreme ef3 and
then I could go king h2 King to g3 and
I've made some progress with making
I get to the third-ranked successfully
and who knows what beyond that maybe I
there's a timely
you know King running up here and maybe
I weave a mate but
doing this paves the way for my king
activity so it just wants to go without
it still wants to play over here I just
thought they would go here and this pawn
is defended but then I wouldn't need
both of my rooks on this file that could
do some other stuff
yeah you know what now I'm seeing that
there's probably way to just win this
pond
and then I could maybe cash out
and when the a for pond so once you go
with H for King g3
and yeah and try to hunt this pawn down
right because King here I have these
checks yeah so I guess I should have
tried to first win the H pawn and only
then returned to go ahead and sacrifice
on a four
and also maybe I could still slowly inch
up some with my kingside pawns before
capturing the a pond
now maybe in on this endgame I could
play it where I don't necessarily have
to capture the a pawn just keep one rook
behind here and one of my other books is
free to do something else form some kind
of a battery on the fifth or sixth ranks
seventh rank
okay so that would have been a better
option objectively but I wanted to make
it a little bit simple and this isn't
Club this isn't really a winning
advantage okay I guess now it is with
some accurate moves plus two point seven
plus three oh I played h4 King to age
four
I guess we're just going to
go hunting here king h4 suppose this we
go here suppose that we go here and on
this move oh this kind of a push
mmm
he gets flushed really far back and then
there's something like this giving
pitching up upon pitching upon okay
that's something that really needs to be
calculated well this idea of keeping the
h4 square open for
a king March up the board not just to
win the pawn but you know really looking
to improve the King yeah I put the pawn
there
be knocking h4
and yeah in this this position okay yeah
now it's winning but if they didn't
allow this move I think I was still
going to struggle to show some progress
yeah I'm going to struggle to show that
this is a win and just have these moves
which is we're just repeating now
okay I'd have to come up with something
else but what is what is what are these
suggestions it's tough to find a way
forward changing the structure with this
could try but I think this is just going
to be a draw now
yeah got a little lucky there in this
end game that they allowed the e5 move
they should be able to hold this one to
a drum
they just have to watch out for this one
a little trick with d5 they didn't they
were they were down on time and yeah
that in game I guess I should it was a
little bit too fast to give up the
material I could have squeezed out a
little bit more maybe picked up the
h-bomb before going in for that exchange
okay well anyhow
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
to this 15 - game in the comment section
below what we're having a great day and
I will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye